hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the machine
I need you've got some story the machine
sorry almost forever ah so far so good
and I bet this does oh yeah no ha what
Oh Keith there we go
Melky now I can open that door huh ha
yeah I think I should be more concerned
that there are murdered people around
like this triplet it worked
hot damn Oh oops don't mind me I'm
probably never run back I'll leave that
open oh my oh whatever it is under ha ha
ha ha what the hell and a skull it was a
skull in the last explosion what's with
the skulls what's with these barrels is
that something out of her some honor
some secret secret secret secret secret
secret
kissy secret secret Tara crap come on
nothin nothin nothin nothin not a damn
thing not a ding dong damn ah my oil
damn it I'm using way too much that
sorry guys I'm stupid there we go ok all
right no more explosions gonna freak me
out
the machine is out to get me
so the machines fault I'm gonna go get
to see the machine
that's cool
I don't know if you see that loading
screens custom always good time
still quiet very very unnerving lis
quiet there's music huh what the hell is
that
ah whoa what the hell whoa where'd that
come from
whoa uh-oh step hi it's you again you
you son of a [ __ ] uh it's the UH guard
um I get the feeling that the machine
isn't a monster so much is just like the
darkness I wonder if they're even gonna
throw a monster at me hello my lord
after several unexpected events that
happened last week at the lower levels
of our machinery I found it very
important to lock the first security
gate last night we heard strange noises
coming from the laboratory room and a
few of my subordinates refused to
continue their work I am sure you won't
blame me for this moreover I hope that
we will soon resolve that issue
sincerely mr. Paul yes unfortunately I
have lost my security gate manual I
don't exactly know which level opens the
gate I am sure that it is important to
combine two levers to open it one turns
the steam source on or the second winter
EXA steam into the proper engine but
there's a problem
one lever opens the hidden door the
laboratory we don't know what is going
on here
unnecessary Commerce everywhere you look
one two whoo all right up ha oh my god
can i ah
knock it off no no no go back on
I didn't mean to hope I didn't ruin
everything
oh is that supposed to happen
oops honk honk I didn't know you can
knock these wheels by I can turn the
wheel with another wheel yo dog wheel
ception wicked anyway um whatever don't
matter I just need to open this one and
find like a hand crank or something
willy-nilly willy-nilly but get up there
Wow Wow I got it something I'm so smart
don't mind the barrels a lot of barrels
in here
okay hold it here to the Zeppelin care
about the Zeppelin I'll zip your lid and
up
I'll have the right type of oil
huh so listen
someone could a ba oil got your oil mine
I wasted like a whole full thing of oil
just exploring in the last part
willy-nilly willy-nilly willy-nilly
I see crack
I have no idea what I'm doing
you know that music is kind of getting
to me I like the silence a little bit
better what's this
oh is this affecting that no you seem
like it no it's just steam okay
um ah here we go ah heart let's that
wasn't what I wanted
oh maybe I need to find another pipe
yeah um probably the other room
I probably overlooked it cuz I wasn't
looking for it in the first place Oh
over down here hi give me a pipe huh ah
okay I broke everything else in here I
might as well break you oil large oil
potion potion of oil that is dark
why does nothing have adequate lighting
those are my last Turner box no trapdoor
no not early I am not that old Civil War
clothes
broom what are you doing here bro you
look suspicious lamp oh don't feel right
oh hello hot an arm as agreed as agreed
oh my people have inserted a solid steam
bulkheads to control the lower passage
okay these people are really asleep
don't speak English is the first
language by McCutchen you can open it by
turning the valve which we have built
inside the control room upstairs of
course you will need to turn the steam
engine on first just direct the steam
source to end number one turn on the
electrics electricity capacitor on and
set the lever combination to the proper
one default is up down up okay up down
up
knock down up up whoo
oh god blackness up down up up down oh
oh yeah Oh Shawn wasn't that right or do
I still need to find another one for
this we up down up electricity's on
can't move it off so I'm guessing that's
fine
um let me go check the other room so far
nothing scary happening I shouldn't miss
it up ah
no hmm oh I didn't check in here
aha uh nope room Mountain dance with me
in here ah
tinderbox give you this
um I'm not seeing any more pipes don't
know what to do about this um
you're creeping me out
stop it oh gosh I'm lost again I'm lost
okay I can't go back because of the
whole cave-in situation
no piped over here pipes up there
Heights over here no pipes no pipes
pipes no puppy I'll pipe a pipe plug it
through there this is correct right up
down up so then that's what it said I
need to open the bulkheads if I want to
make progress make a progress not
progress a progress destruct the steam
source 2 engine number 1 turn on
electricity capacitor and set lever
combination to a proper one you follow
this up down Oh maybe um those levers up
up up in the other room maybe I didn't
get the combination right I don't even
know what it opened if anything let me
try something else I mean I just guessed
in the one with the first one that did
it linkie do okay I can't move that one
anymore
ok never mind that was perfect the way I
did it
I'm just perfect the way I am
um maybe turn this the other way
oh man that music is getting creepy
it's kind of confusing there's a lot a
lot of Direction missing like nothing no
text saying oh I need to do flaw or oh
that looked strange or blue
there's a pipe over there nope none of
that all pipes all pipes no pies for me
alright I'm smart enough to figure this
out do it
maybe with those a pipe down they're
always possible what is this I can't
turn it
I can't smash it I can't do anything
with it
so what's the point of it yeah ah yeah
oh that creeped me out that that thing
actually huh nevermind getting freaked
out at random crap yeah sure herb not
sewer I don't even know probably sincere
cop Dora that's the world
let me grow mmm yeah maybe they're about
trapdoors where I thought I couldn't
open it and then head open so but
apparently that is not the case here
it's so bleeding dark I'm wasting oil
all over the place
ah I didn't know working I did what it
said to you electricity I hear the
clicking laggy crackalacka lakal I did
the up down up I redirected to steam
engine one I think
what do you want from me what do you
want from me maybe try down up down Oh
nope nuttin not a damn thing
hmm okay it's your own Yuna and I'm out
of oil fantastic run straight out of oil
because he's just yeah electricity on
just dear okay open it by turning the
valve which we have built inside the
control room upstairs of course you will
need to turn the steam engine on first
just direct the steam source 2 engine
number 1 ok let me go back up to that
room things don't like to click in this
game so maybe if I just really [ __ ]
the kajigger ah what what what the hell
what was that ah Oh kill your box
I need ah what the heck e heck was that
where you don't death duck girl damn
huh huh huh how was that huh huh Oh God
the head
I know I don't even know huh
I don't even know ah what oh crap
alright that was something
woo all right that's all the time I got
for this episode
oh man that [ __ ] - like like I go up
there I've gone up there like five times
nothing happened and then all son don't
go down down oh no no no no no none okay
anyway ah that's all the time we got for
this episode thank you guys so much for
watching and as always we'll see you in
the next part
bye bye